now however we're going to switch over
to our field correspondent josephine
chang i've named her the senior hallway
bureau chief josephine uh great spot to
reel in some researchers right right
there in the hallway i like that
promotion can i get a raise too thank
you um it is after lunch so people are
feeling really rejuvenated and i've
managed to snag in the hallway here jack
sankovic from the university of virginia
welcome thank you i know your specialty
is in sort of the network of wireless
sensors that are everywhere i mean there
are mechanical things like cars and
airplanes that are in health care
systems in the hospitals and they're
starting to be in the home
yeah so i give a talk called smart homes
smart phones and beyond and so in that
work we're trying to establish
the collection of physiological and
behavioral information for
elderly and then we can use this to look
detect anomalies and detect uh say
medical problems early and this is
really the future i think and
the smartphone is also wellness and
we've developed techniques for example
to control heart rate
with music
and so you can really try to improve
people's lives in this way and you were
saying that with their phone you could
even target to within 10 percent of like
if you weren't aimed for a specific
heart rate to what's healthy of course
right so the idea is that
if you're
wandering around and your heart rate is
too high and you're not doing anything
and it shouldn't be high then we would
recommend music to lower it and if
you're doing cardiovascular exercises
then you have specific
heart rates you want to achieve and so
we would also be able to achieve those
heart rates for you
and then as far as the home i mean our
homes are getting smarter all the time
with smart appliances and so forth but
you're also talking about um sort of
tracking or monitoring people's
behaviors and emotional states
yes and
uh
well
by taking different kinds of parameters
about the person say voice
their
their skin conductance and many other
factors
you can detect what behaviors they're
doing and how they feel about it from
voice you can get mood and stress so you
can take all of these factors into
account and getting a big picture of a
human being
and we found that it takes
even for elderly who are not that active
say that we end up with say 10 to 35
models that describe
a person's behaviors and
emotional states and that way you can
tell when something is different when
something's off that's right and the
real trick though is to avoid too many
false alarms so any system if you deploy
it
and it requires
lots of false
results in lots of false alarms then
nobody's going to use the system right
so crying wolf too many times right yeah
so we have a very sophisticated uh
semantic anomaly detection scheme that
will
determine when a false alarm is really a
false alarm and it includes semantic
rules and it's probably i think the most
sophisticated system available
interesting well you know harry shim was
talking about how we all have so many
devices now like up to 27 devices per
person so how do you avoid like one set
of sensors telling you one thing and
another set of sensors telling you
something else right so so our vision is
that a home would be
a sensing actuation infrastructure would
be a utility like like electricity or
water and then people will build
applications and run those applications
on the system
now what we
thought about is
you can think of this as the right app
doesn't know what the left app is doing
yeah and so what we're doing is
identifying how apps interfere with each
other automatically and try to detect
and resolve inconsistencies so you
wouldn't have one app opening the window
like just say to
improve the air quality in the house for
medical purpose and another app closing
it for energy and the windows going up
and down up and down so
our schemes help detect those conflicts
and resolve those conflicts and they
will happen more and more often as more
apps are put into homes i can see how
this is great for people who want to age
in their home you know this is a real
trend these days people do not want to
go to nursing homes they want to stay in
their homes and having a smart home can
really enable people to do that that's
absolutely true and i think this is the
first case where
technology can actually lower medical
costs yeah almost all other medical
devices increase costs they may improve
your health but they
increase costs and here i think there's
a chance of reducing costs so not only
staying in your home is more amenable to
people but it's going to be a lot less
expensive than putting them in nursing
homes or assisted living even right and
also sometimes that detecting problems
early you can treat it earlier yes
absolutely and you know you want to to
form the systems into a wellness version
so that
people are healthier longer and
if
problems are
happening then the system needs to be
adaptable to that and people's medical
conditions change so you can't build a
system that simply
looks for depression for example because
later they may have parkinson's disease
and so you need to be able to have a
system that evolves from as a person's
medical condition gets better or worse
that sounds fantastic how far down the
road are we looking when are we going to
see these things smart homes
some of them are there now
but
they are somewhat limited in the sense
what i call that they don't address
realisms very well
and what i mean by that is
take an acoustic sensor that's listening
for voice to detect mood
well we have very strong signal
processing algorithms that can do that
in quiet environments but you put it in
a home right and you have a bus driving
by you have the tv on so then the signal
processing algorithms tend to fall apart
unless you have good filters and other
techniques to handle realisms so we have
to deal with that maybe in a few years
huh
well at some levels
you can start to see results even today
and there are thousands of homes now
with smart
sensing for elderly but again they're
somewhat limited in detecting falls or
you know some simpler
techniques simpler problems important
work though thank you so much jack i
appreciate you talking with us about
this
all right
we are also trying to take more
researchers as they come by here manuel
come over here hi
this is manuel hermena gildo from madrid
spain
welcome thank you very much welcome to
redmond washington you know um i know
that you work with mdea software
institute which is also does joint
research with microsoft tell us about
them dear what does it do we are a
research center in madrid
which we concentrate on building the
tools and the techniques and the science
the technology that essentially to build
tools to help programmers build
applications that we can trust
applications that uh you know that
preserve or our privacy that we can uh
that don't break on us that don't
you know end up giving us the wrong data
et cetera so how to do that in an
efficient way in a cost-effective way so
you build the tools for software
engineers software developers and
programmers to be able to do their work
how about your research in particular
what do you focus on
that's great well um
we work in
uh the microsoft india research center
the research which is a very exciting
development that that is very recent um
as far as our own research we work on
energy analysis energy consumption
analysis we work in a lot of
topics on programming languages and so
on but energy is probably the most
exciting thing we're doing really like
what what is what is the energy
consumption analysis what you're doing
energy comes energy is a big concern
it's a you know if you think from large
computing uh centers to small devices
you're worried about how much uh it's
costing to consume so much energy how
much you're heating the environment or
you're running out of battery on your
wearable device so it's a very big deal
an exciting thing is that um
the uh you know the savings that you can
do in energy consumption come a lot from
the software i mean a lot of can be done
by the hardware but also can also be
done on the software side so that's
that's that's what we work on this is
joint work with um pedro lopez there in
madrid and with
xmos and
and and also bristol and what we do is
we have models of how much
energy individual instructions
need and then we integrate that over the
whole program
and uh get functions that tell you how
much the program consumes and that
allows you to do things like
um have specifications of how much
energy this has to
consume and verify them or find energy
bugs so this program is has a bug
because it's using too much energy
or how can i optimize this program so
that in my timing constraints i only use
the minimum amount of memory and that
might require lowering the voltage or
going slower
cetera so we try to give programmers
tools to be able to do this
in a very simple way just pushing a
button the same way we check types
nowadays for example that's good i wish
there was these institutes for all kinds
of professions but you know programmers
their work is a little bit changing
because the amount of data that's you
know out there and and the amount of
computers they have to program for does
that change you know the the work that
they do and how they do their work
oh these tools are absolutely uh
game changing i think because
you know the the there's been a
tremendous advance in the uh quality or
the the complexity of the properties
that we can that we can
check
the programming language has also
evolved a lot
obviously but these two these
environments and the analysis and
verification tools that we are starting
now to build and to uh
to progress um
they really have changed like i said the
game in the sense that programmers now
are much more confident come much faster
find uh bugs they can also
and we're much closer to the elusive
goal of having uh
oral software being certified
this is this is one of the
main focuses of this joint research
center that we have with microsoft where
we do things like this we do
verification we do um
cryptography we do privacy analysis we
do
memory models concurrency
and web security malware detection etc
there are things aimed at making
uh building the confidence of the user
in the in the software right so do you
like coming to the faculty summit
because it lets you have access and you
may you could hear from so many of the
people who are working on you know who
are going to be using your products oh
yeah oh yeah
there's a lot of interesting people here
very this there's this is really a very
good selection of top people in
in computer science in it in general and
it's a great opportunity to work with
people at microsoft and outside
microsoft to uh start collaboration to
continue previous collaboration so yeah
it's exciting to be here do you get new
ideas when you're
you know among among intellectual peers
like this oh yeah that's why we come to
these conferences of course yeah
yeah definitely definitely yeah every
time you know we come to a conference
like this you know we start
you know around the table we had some
ideas and then papers ideas prototypes
come out all the time that's great well
i hope you enjoy the rest of the faculty
summit it's a pleasure talking with you
manuel thank you very much